sinha dopes was that your idea or if
Scylla dubs was a it was a project that
existed before I came on my two of my
producing partner is actually the
executive producers Angeline Rose Troy
and Scott roughgarden had this project
for 23 years I think and they were
trying to get it done as a feature film
at that time I had a friendship with
Scott and he knew that I was looking for
my first directing project because I've
been producing for about 10-12 years now
and been trying to get back to directing
which is what I had started in
originally in theater and so Scott knew
I was looking for a project and he ended
up with this project that had funding a
small amount of funding and a script but
it wasn't ready to shoot the script
needed a lot of work and so when he
brought me on he said we've got money
we've got a script the script isn't
isn't ready to shoot but you know would
you be interested and of course you know
being a you know needing to get that
first directing credit under my belt to
get back into the TV world directing I
said I'm gonna make this work so we went
over the script and decided it needed a
page-one rewrite and Scott had a another
friend of his Brian drolet who was a
great writer had just done a movie that
was very like funny comedy that had you
know all sorts of elements of broad
humor and physical comedy and you know a
lot of the things that I felt like Sinha
doubs could be if it had gotten you know
if it got with the right group of
creative people and I took a look at
that movie was called dumbbells and I
took a look at that movie i looked at
the trailer and I was like look if he
can just do what he did in the dumbbells
trailer where it's just wall-to-wall
jokes and funny humor and great funny
characters that we're gonna have a
winner here and Scott called up Brian
and he wrote a first draft just in no
time at all i think in like a weekend
and at that point it was like we've got
a good team here and we had a great you
know we had a great synergy between the
three of us
to get it going and then we added Scylla
Campbell as a producer and PEG leave as
a producer and another writer and you
know and there it was when you looked at
the script and you saw that it needed
work what were some of the notes that
all of you had what just just for other
people that have a script that they're
not totally sure about what were the
notes oh man I mean they needed a page 1
rewrite so some of the notes I think I
am a big I it was written as a feature
film script and I'm a big believer in
following story the story arc of
characters you know and not just non
sequitur sort of relationships that
occur throughout a story but in really
having them start at one place and then
traveled to the next place in the jury
and maybe that's the makii sort of
standard element standard structure that
I that I do like I would say that would
be number one there weren't clear story
arcs for the characters we didn't see
them start in one position and finish in
another another element was that a lot
of the humor was not really you know the
jokes may have been more for shock value
but they weren't they were playing as as
you know funny we didn't care about the
characters if you don't you don't care
about the characters that are in the
situation's then you won't get
emotionally invested in them and and
then you won't allow yourself to be
carried along that journey that that you
know that ultimately ends in not only
joke payoffs but at the at the end of
the day a satisfying sort of feeling of
like yeah I get I know these people I'm
with them I I know what it's like to
sort of be in their shoes for the 15
minutes i'm watching this episode um
what else was it uh and of course it was
written as a feature wasn't it wasn't
split up in two episodes and and I you
know it's funny I had to do I broke up
another feature film script that I that
I'm
part of in two episodes and it actually
it kind of helps you as a writer because
if you either call them episodes or acts
or whatever but at the end of the day
you're forced to have sort of a
beginning middle and end to the smaller
pieces of the total script so that you
end up getting in under the hood and
really tooling you know really getting
these scenes up to speed and then when
you string them all together again it's
like oh I can see that I'm feeling in
every scene there's a beginning middle
and end in every scene there's a little
bit of a conflict and then they move on
with the story and and I think that sort
of that sort of process where you go up
and you end up breaking down your your
your your larger project into the
smaller pieces and make sure that you're
getting those payoffs at every turn not
just overall I think that's another
thing that it really has helped you know
to change it into a serious script
versus that original feature script
you